Egypt right this very second within the
last 20 minutes it was announced that
the military coup is underway Mohamed
Morsi who is the Muslim Brotherhood
candidate who a president who was
elected democratically after Mubarak
ille you know was let go after 30 years
he is now on his way out so any of this
could change within the hour that it
takes for us to post this there's so
many ways we can start this thing and
it's a really really big topic that
they've basically been ignoring in the
news but so first what how do Americans
you have should Americans even feel
about this because there's a feeling in
America I think that we just should have
nothing to do with the world anymore
like we got so many problems at home
that we can't worry about this is that
is that as a bad route to take for
America I feel like we have to worry to
some degree but it's so tricky and I
think Obama has had such a tough time
knowing how much to say how much to do
and I think he did you know sort of miss
uh he came in a little late in that when
the Muslim Brotherhood started after
they came into power doing all these
things were that we're not exactly
correct women's rights out the window
yeah they weren't he wasn't really he
wasn't speaking up enough in time but
then there is the whole debate it's this
is not our country these are not our
people why do we as Americans say well
we are in charge of everything and we're
sort of big brother and we always get to
have a say and yeah ironically not our
country we gave the Muslim Brotherhood
1.3 billion dollars last month I'm
pretty sure perhaps it could have been
used for better fun what do you think
what do you think America is supposed to
should our involvement be nothing are we
supposed to take a side do up what side
are we on you even know that you know
what I think we're on our own side you
know as usual um I think that we're
always involved in any international you
know affairs or disputes or anything I
think that's kind of what we're known
for why we're loved and while we're
hated you know to be quite honest row
sticking her nose in someone else's
where the Wendy Williams of the world
there now second I Rosen someone else's
ibid all you do ND um no but seriously
it's it's it's a hard line to walk like
you said it's a hard balance you don't
want to be over involved you don't want
to be under involved obviously we care
what's going on there
and we have completely different
democracy even after they brought in
this new electoral votes all that it
still turned out to be the same ending
unfortunately these people took a chance
they thought that they were changing the
Constitution they thought they were
changing the way the oppression all of
that and it as it turned out they had a
guy that was worse than the last guy
they just kicked out right now is all of
that just part of democracies growing
pains because it seems to me they had
Mubarak for 30 years nobody really liked
and they were really free but at least
he kept some sort of order right then
they they've had democracy and that's
the irony it's like what are we supposed
to do now I write because they did
democratically elect this guy and Obama
said a lot of nice things about this guy
and military kooser are not comfortable
things for Americans to really wrap
their heads around I think and rightly
so yeah you know it's yes the Egyptians
have every right to be angry and to be
protesting and this man should not be in
office and yet military kuz that's some
intense stuff right is there any that's
the thing it's like no matter what
happens so you go from a dictator to a
democratically elected guy who's no good
to now a military coup we have no reason
is the military suddenly gonna be like
all right women's rights Reverend you're
gay right to give super fair I'm gonna
say keep in mind i feel like they took
one giant step forward and then like ten
steps back because typically egypt has
always been ruled either by an old
military commander someone you know
something to do the military this is
sort of the first time and they thought
oh my god this is great we're finally
you know gonna gonna have some freedoms
and and things like that and i think
that this guy you know it was bait and
switch to be honest I mean if I'm gonna
put this in a min funny metaphor it's
like you know you're dating a girl that
she's hot she's got long hair she's got
the lashes of the nails and then you
take her home and you wake up the next
morning and she's bald and crazy you
know it's just like wait a minute like
who is you know misrepresentation so um
so yeah you know I think that right now
the role that we're taking it's it's
we're covering it we have our opinions
on it obviously there at the end of the
day it's there it's their land and
they're gonna do what they want to do
I'm with you on this crazy metaphor
though because I was watching a YouTube
clip from last year with Christiane
Amanpour from CNN interviewing Morsi and
he's going on and on about how much he
loves democracy
freedom and women's rights because of
you yes great guy great guy that's what
I mean obviously it was totally bait and
switch and I mean we should be calling
this catfish you know it's like he's
letting himself as one thing you show up
and you're like where's the person that
I whatever i'm here i'm so obviously he
had an agenda he's probably muslim
brotherhood I mean that is pretty you
know cut and dry fortunately man under
Mubarak again not defending move our but
this was a group that was banned for
being so extreme under right so better
the devil you know than the devil you
don't they say are three and I think
that that yeah well I mean no all right
so last point of this is there some
every time I when I'm watching this now
I keep thinking this is like watching a
reality TV version of the Ten
Commandments that's what this feels like
to me doesn't it I feel like Charlton
Heston's gonna walk out and go let my
people go yeah like that was what is
that help but do we need those things do
we need those things to frame it like I
feel like that's a simple way to frame
it you know you mean like there's this
group of people like like everyone watch
the Ten Commandments there's this group
of people that wants to be free and
Pharaoh morsi's not letting them be free
and now all hell is about to break loose
yeah it's always easier to be like let
the people speak and be free and
absolutely and that's where my heart is
and I think that's where so many
Americans hearts because we are you know
your frame or something like 14 million
people are out there protesting and 13
million voted more CN right so but at
the same time it's obviously so much
more complex and that's why I mean it's
the first time in history where the
people are actually for the military lab
before it was like they were against it
now they're like a row yeah we're all
named Theia no no jumping on tanks but
um but yeah I think it said it's
unfolding as we speak and we'll see how
it goes and you know hopefully hopefully
it'll be good and and it turns out well
for the stop talking on TV all right
well I think I think we gave you as
insightful if not more than anything
you're going to see on CNN all week